Rob Manning: For the few
people who aren't familiar
with your work how do
you describe what you do
and what you do online, or
what you do in education?
Sal Khan: Khan Academy is
most known for this collection
of videos that I somewhat famously started
making for my cousins, and
then they caught on, and
people who were not my
cousins started watching
them, but by the time it
kind of got serious traction,
and I had quit my former
job in finance to do
this full-time, and set
it up as a not-for-profit.
Our support has really
kind of allowed us to focus
on not only the videos,
not only translating the
videos, but trying to
build an entire interactive
platform so students
can get instruction, do
practice, if they have a
teacher or parent who can
be their coach. Those folks
will get information on
where the students are at,
what are their strengths,
what are their weaknesses.
And so, the Khan Academy
on one level it's kind of
free tutoring for anybody.
It's a not-for-profit, everything is free.
Our mission is a free
world class education for
anyone anywhere, but on
a deeper level we've kind
of fallen into this situation
and it kind of speaks
to where we are in history,
maybe, where it seems
like we're a catalyst for
helping people think about
what a classroom could
be now. I've never been a
big believer that it should
be virtual only, but it feels
like now the virtual can handle
certain parts of the equation.
It frees up the classroom to do
maybe more interesting things.
Rob: And what dimensions
exactly do you think virtual
education or online does
arguably better than
direct instruction from
a classroom teacher?
Sal: It's kind of a
careful answer just because
I think the ideal is you
have both. The real ideal
is if you had a one-on-one
with a human being,
but that's not practical,
you know, only kind of
lords and dukes had that
hundreds of years ago.
What we're seeing is students
when they are getting
together with people in
the physical environment
we think the best use of
that is not the lecture,
the one pace fits all
lecture, the best use of
that time is for the
human beings to actually
interact. They're all
in the room together.
And so, where online
strength is, is on delivering
what used to be that lecture
in a way that it's not
one way pace fits all any
more, so that a student
can pause and repeat at their own time,
at their own pace. If
they're embarrassed by
maybe they're in 8th grade
and they forgot something
from 4th grade they don't
have to have the guts
to raise their hand in
class. They can just
look at those concepts
and no one is going to
judge them. If they're
ready to move ahead they
can move ahead. Software
is also really good at
kind of generating exercises,
grading the exercises,
doing a lot of the
logistics that frankly take
teachers away from the
actual teaching part of
their job, and so what we're
saying is in a traditional
classroom a lot of a
teacher's time is spent
giving this lecture to
a bunch of students.
Often times the classroom
is fairly passsive at
those moments. A lot of
the teacher's time is
kind of the administrative
work of writing exams,
grading exams, and maybe
10-15% of their time is
spent with the actual
one-on-one interaction,
or small group interaction with students.
We're saying with technology
we can take a lot of
the information delivery,
the logistics, a lot of
the problems, set creation,
and grading off of a
teacher's plate. A 100 percent
of their time could be
the one-on-one connections
with students in the
small group interactions.
Rob: I wonder is part of
the issue that it's the
sort of one too many
kind of dissemination of
information which tends
to be the prevailing
model of instruction that
is somewhat imperfect
anyway. It's sort of,
like, whether you're doing
it the lecture hall in
front of 500 people,
or you've got 500 students online.
Sal: Yeah, and the irony here and
you're talking to someone who has sat
down and made 3,000
videos, or 3,200 now, but
the most important part
of an education is not the
lecture/videos. The most
important part of the education
is doing problem solving,
interacting with people,
and asking questions and answering other
peoples questions, and
in traditional classrooms
that tends to get squeezed
out. You get a little bit
out of it, but it gets
squeezed out by the passive
lecture, so I agree with
you. I think a lecture is
an imperfect thing. I
think it gets a little bit
better when you make it
on demand, when you allow
it to cater to a student's
pace, and then technology
can also understand what's working,
what's not working. You can
start to collect data on
what's effective, what's
not. Traditional lecture
gets very little of that
data. Textbooks get very
little of that data. Now
with online you can have it.
But I think the main focus
is, and it's a bit of the
irony here is that the
technology enables the
classroom to become more
interactive, more human,
and for me, you know, there
are always these debates.
Is technology good? Is it a
cure all? Is it a silver bullet?
Or, is it bad? and, you
know, [unintelligible]
For me the question isn't should or should
you not use technology. The
question is well, what is
the ideal learning
experience? And you try to
answer that question. To
me it's, you know, it's
experience focused on
the student, cater to the
students needs, works
at the students pace,
and then when they're with other
human beings they're
interacting with them, and so
you say, okay, that's the
ideal. Now can we do it?
and 30, 50, 100 years ago
you couldn't economically
do it, you would have to
be quite well-off to have
that type of attention
to personalize education,
but now I think the
answer is we can do it,
we can personalize it in a practical way.
Rob: The instructors
have not been brought up
obviously, in an online
environment, the vast
majority of them, but
they have been brought up
with the concept of
differentiated instruction,
and I wonder there are
some who would argue
well, I can adapt my lecture
to students questions,
to blank stares in the
desks that I'm looking at.
Are there instances where
perhaps in a smaller
environment where maybe a
lecture can be equal to,
or better than, you know, a
video lecture style of delivery?
Sal: Yeah absolutely. There
are certain circumstances.
I think if you have a
very small seminar type
situation that's highly
interactive than that wins,
and actually I would say
that's not a lecture any more,
that's actually what we would want to see
class time used for. I think there is also
moments where shared
experience is very powerful,
and I would say that falls
more in the category of
inspiring, your TED talks
and inspirational speech.
I think there is value
of having many people in
the room and having that
shared moment, but I think
for things that are
intellectually deep, things that
are hard for people to
get their head around,
some person might get it
faster than another person.
I mean me and you we can watch a speech,
a high level speech and
we'll all get it, but
if we're doing calculus,
we're doing chemistry,
you might get it faster
than me. I might get it
faster than you. It's
nearly impossible. Frankly,
if you get even more than
10 or 15 students to cater
to where every student is,
and the only information
that a teacher currently
has is trying to read
the blank stares, trying
to read how engaged the
students are, and you
know, there have been
studies that the average
lecturer is teaching
at the 23rd percentile,
because they're making
sure that no one is falling
behind, and I point out
you might say, well at least 23% of the
students are getting
it, but the reality is
77% are bored, and then 22% it's
going to fast for, so you're only catering
to 1%, and so I won't make a blanket
statement that it's always
better, but I will say
that most of the time
when you have human beings
together it's better for
them to interact with
each other, to ask questions
of each other, than
for them to just kind
of sit passively and be
given a lecture. And a lot of times when
people say, well in a
live lecture you can ask
questions, and I say, yeah absolutely.
Today in a traditional
lecture hall that's maybe
5% of class time, and that's usually
only the bravest people in the class, and
sometimes even the question
might not be appropriate
for everyone. We'd like
to see where it's 100%
of the class time, and it's not just
asking the teacher questions,
it's not just asking
the TA questions, but it's
also asking your peers
questions where the
students themselves get
that deeper experience of explaining
things to their colleagues.
Rob: You see there still
being a 50/50 split,
and maybe that's not the
right percentage, but
at least a part that's online,
a part that's in class,
have you heard people
or what's your response
to people saying, well,
you know, maybe we can
do more of the discussion
part online as well,
whether it's through
chat rooms and skyping,
or whatever, what's the
problem, or why should
that remain in the classroom,
or why not, you know,
ship that into the online
environment as well?
Sal: I think we should
all experiment on what
type of social experiences,
constructive social
experiences you can
have online, and I think
in some domains, you
know, doing skype could be
very valuable for foreign
language. I mean the
goal standard has always
been immersion. If you
can't afford immersion
you skype with somebody
who speaks that language
and maybe you could get
interesting results, you
know, we see on our site
we have 60 million students
use the site every month.
We want them to interact
with each each other.
We want them to answer their
questions. With that said,
and that's incredibly
valuable for someone who
maybe does not have
someone to interact with.
They don't have access to a kind of a rich
environment, but I think
the technology would have
to go a very, very long
way to come close to
what you could get with
a very rich classroom
environment that's led
by an inspiring teacher.
But when I say led, not
meaning lectured by an
inspiring teacher, but
really mentored and coached
by an inspiring teacher.
Rob: Given that these are a different set
of skills from teachers,
from what teachers have
been really brought up
in, do you have a vision
for how to kind of get to
the sort of 21st century
flipped classroom instructor that
we would need to do this?
Sal: Yeah, and it's an open question.
I don't know 100%, I mean, it's actually
exciting to be here at a school that is so
focused on education. I
suspect a lot of the answer
might be for the future
teachers to experience
it themselves, for them
to understand it, and
for them to viscerally
feel the difference between
being lectured at, and
being able to engage with
the content, and have
conversations with their
peers, and discuss it
at a deeper level, but
I think we're just at
the very early stages.
In my opinion it seems
like a lot of the adoption
is happening faster than
I would have guessed.
We're being used in 20,000
classrooms right now.
This is really just over
the last couple of years,
and we have two people who
engage directly with classrooms.
We're a very small
organization, so it seems like
there's a hunger out there.
A lot of the teachers
we talked to this is kind
of the direction they've
always wanted to be in, they've wanted to.
They got into the profession
because they wanted
to connect with students.
They wanted to be
that teacher that takes
that student from a
certain attitude to where
they're taking ownership
of their life, and they
found it difficult when they
have 30 faces that they
have to kind of lecture at.
Rob: All right, and one
thing that I've heard
as sort of a concern from
teachers is that there
might be a ... Maybe I'll put it this way.
The concerns have not
come just from teachers,
but that online learning
often gets sold as
a cost saving, you know,
is something that we ...
Public education is
very expensive. What can
we do to save money? Do
you think it is a viable
way to do education less expensively?
Sal: I kind of ... I don't
know, is the simple answer.
I mean, I know for my own
kids I don't want them
online only, and I, you
know the way I view it is if
education was perfect
we should think about
how we can then, you
know, if we're making a
great car we can then think
about how to streamline
the factory or whatever
we're doing, but, you know,
the reality and there's a million alarmist
articles that come out
about all the reasons
why we should worry about
education, and so in my mind
I would not try to
de-resource the problem.
I would try to maybe hold resources costs,
or maybe even potentially
increase them, but
try to get, but try to
have better outcomes,
and so, I view technology
as much more of given
whatever resources you
have and it's hard to
argue that you're ever
putting too many resources
in education. Given
whatever resources you have
how do we actually optimize outcomes?
Rob: You've had a good
time doing the videos.
I mean, I don't think
you'd do 3,000 of them
if you didn't like doing them.
Sal: Yes, no. I like
doing them a lot, yes.
Rob: Do you have any particular favorites
that you were sort of
like, you know, or have
you heard from people
what are particularly
fond of a certain video?
Sal: Oh, you know,
there's a bunch. I mean,
well I think one of the ... people ask me.
What's the trick? How do you ... ? and
I say the video that
I'm doing I could try to
convince myself that's
my favorite video, so
that you literally have,
like, you know, you
hear the energy, you hear the excitement,
and you can't understate
how important those
cues are for the student.
If the lecturer themselves
does not care about it the
student immediately ...
We're very sensitive to
that. If you're saying
the next step in this
equation, I mean, whose
going to care about
that, and so I think it's
very important for the
lecturer themselves to
feel excited that they get to do this, but
there's all sorts of
topics. I'm a real big fan
of the cosmology videos.
It was a reason for me
to learn a lot of cosmology
and really understand
it, and it's something
that always fascinated me.
But I get into the finance
videos. My whole life
I was an analyst at an
investment firm, and
obviously there's a
certain part of me that
gets very passionate
about that. I love doing
the history videos. I
love doing ... I mean
I like doing it all.
Rob: You get some pushback
from educators who
are, like, well he didn't
go to education school,
he didn't, you know,
do you feel like maybe
teaching is not as hard as
people make it out to be?
Sal: Well no, actually
I think it's probably
harder than people make it out to be.
And, you know, depending
on what you call a
teacher it's, you know, you can determine
whether I am one, or whether
I'm a content creator.
I don't have to, or I
mean depending on how
you do it, you know, I
don't have 30 live students
that I'm trying to cater
to that I'm ... Some of
them might have some problem at home.
Some of them have some
issue. Some are struggling.
That is a nuanced and
deep and important role
that I am not doing when I
just make a nice resource,
when I make this nice
video. Hopefully, it's an
engaging video and gets
people excited about
the subject matter and, you
know, I want to stress this.
I recently met Wendy Kopp, at dinner, the
founder of Teach for America, and she was
telling me that the
single biggest determinant
of the teachers that they
have, and they studied
this very carefully. What are the teachers
that are showing outsized
gains? And most people
think it's going to be
content delivery, and
there is some correlation. If someone can
deliver a good lecture
then their students tend
to do well, but the thing that really
moves the dial is the
teachers ability to change
the students mindsets.
To make the students
realize that they really
have to take ownership
of their learning, that
they really have to
start thinking about
their futures, and when
she said that I was, like,
well I need to quote you,
and I'm quoting her
right now because that's
very consistent with what we're saying.
Instead of 5 or 10% of a teacher's time
being that coach, that
inspiration, and 90%
being the content delivery we want 100%
of a teacher's time being that coach, that
inspiration, that person
in the student's life
that can change their
mindset, that can change
their outlook, that can
be that mentor, and that's
something I'll never be able
to do as a video creator,
and you need a live human being for.
Rob: Do you think
there's much of a stretch
between standing in front
of a group of 25 students,
and doing an exercise at the board versus
doing an exercise in
a YouTube video that's
going to be seen at home?
Sal: You know we've been,
and we're constantly
looking for folks to make
more and more videos,
and obviously there's
some incredible teachers
out there, many, many incredible teachers,
but we found that there's
a certain nervousness
once you record yourself
and you put it out there
for the world to see
and comment on, and so,
yes, there is a difference
when you, I mean I
actually don't think
about it. When I make a
video I kind of just imagine
my cousins listening,
and I think it just makes
it more intimate and warm,
hopefully, but we have seen
folks who are, I think,
amazing teachers in
physical form, but when they
know they're being recorded they
tend to get a little nervous.
Rob: And I think teachers
are accustomed to making
relationships, or forming
relationships with
students that they have
right in front of them,
and there's this
uncertainty around well how
am I relating, how are
students relating to me
when they see me on their
computer and is that,
obviously you started
with your cousins, so
I don't know if you ever
sort of went through
that period of uncertainty?
Sal: Yeah. No, I go through
that period of uncertainty
every time I upload a
video, and this is what's
exciting these days is I
can upload a video now,
and within an hour I'll
get 50 comments from
kids of all ages. I
shouldn't say just kids,
all over the world, and it matters to me.
I mean, it really helps me. If you say
"that really helped, that
was exactly what I needed,"
I've gotten through
that concept now, and so
in that way I get much
more direct feedback.
You know, I've done ... I've never been a
professional teacher, but
I've done some teaching
in college and, you know,
I used to give a lecture
or teach a class and the day would go by,
no feedback, I'd get
insecure about it. (laughs)
And that would happen
and maybe at the end of
the term you might get
one or two students,
if you're lucky, who
might say, "oh that was
really helpful, you
know, thank you," but you
don't get that direct
feedback as often, and
you know, online you get that feedback
for better or for worse.
Sometimes the feedback
can be harsh, but once again,
that can only make you better.
Rob: Would you expect every instructor to
produce their own content,
or do you think that
there could be just a standardized
repository that teachers would draw from?
Sal: I think both. I mean,
I'd like to see a world
where every instructor
if they're not happy
with what they're seeing
out in the world that they
are creating their own, and say hey, I can
do better than that,
that persons not covering
this nuance or this angle,
let me do something.
With that said, I can
imagine over time the
content delivery, you know, just as every
teacher is not writing
their own textbook that
you kind of start to settle on it becomes
reasonably resource intensive. Now we can
actually use data and
analytics to figure out
which of the videos,
and once again, I think
the videos in some ways
they're an analogist
to the text in the
textbook, but we can start
to measure how effective
is it, how engaging is it,
and in 5 or 10 years
we won't need thousands
of explanations of factoring a polynomial.
We could have a handful
that have proven themselves
to really engage students
and resonate with them.
Rob: I have one last question,
if I could, which is the
level of work that this
type of education requires
as opposed to what
teachers are accustomed to
doing now. What I've
heard from one instructor
who does sort of a
hybrid kind of, you know,
does a little bit of
both, he's like, well the
classes that have an
online component you really
have to develop all those
online pieces in advance,
and then you still have
all of the work of the,
you know, regular
interaction with students.
In short, it sounds like it is more work.
It may be worth it, but
do you think that it is
more work and perhaps worth it,
or what's your view on that?
Sal: What we're seeing
is, yeah, I think, today,
in most schools especially
I would say public
schools where a teacher
wants to do something
in this direction it is
more work for them, today,
because to some degree they
have to serve two masters.
They have to serve the
traditional master of
this is the state
curriculum. You have to do
this in this week, but
at the same time, they
want to have the flexibility and allow the
students to work at
their own pace and cater
to the student, so it is
more work for them, today.
It's less work then if they wanted to do a
student centered curriculum
10 years ago without
any technology. With
that said, the direction
that everything seems
to be going in is that
the tools are getting better, you know,
Khan Academy itself is
nowhere near being a
perfect tool. We have a
list of 200 things that
we need to fix about
it, make it easier for
teachers to use, make
it easier for them to
plan their curriculum.
We have to add a lot
more content so that
people don't have to go
and fill in the gaps in other places.
There's other people
making more and more tools.
So I suspect as the tools
get better, as kind of
the curriculum becomes
clearer, I think this
adoption of the common core is actually a
huge opportunity because
states have adopted it.
It hasn't kind of fully gone
into implementation yet.
I think all of these things
are kind of converged.
The technology is going
to become more usable,
and more accessible.
Right now teachers have to
struggle with trying
to get the laptop cart
for their class at the right period.
Hopefully, a lot of
those things are going to
solve themselves over
the next 4 - 5 years.
So, yes, I would say
it's harder today, but
the teachers think it's
worth it, but I would
suspect 5 - 10 years from now it might be
easier than a traditional model.
Rob: Well thanks. I should
probably wrap up now.
I could ask you lots more questions.
Sal: Oh no, no, no, great, great,
yeah, those were great questions.
Rob: I appreciate it.